c'est une victoire pour eric drew et le
délibéré du jugement en appel lui est
totalement favorable
le président de la cour d'appel a
prononcé l'annulation de
l'interpellation pour les faits du 22
décembre 2010 huit annulations de renvoi
des fins de la poursuite la condamnation
est donc annulée et pour les faits du 2
janvier 2019 eh bien c'est la relaxe
pure et simple
pour cette figure des gilet jaune et
rigoureux et est donc totalement blanchi
il ya eu un procès d'appel en juin et
son avocat qui optent larrat avait
plaidé le fait que son client n'avait
pas pu organiser de manifestations
en effet le mouvement des gilet jaune et
horizontal il n'y a pas de chef de
leader donc eric drew et ne pouvait pas
en être un d'ailleurs les décisions sont
prises collectivement au sein de ce
mouvement
et puis pour les faits de janvier est
bien eric drew était venu avec 5 ou 6 g
les jaunes seulement il ne s'agissait
pas à proprement parler d'un
rassemblement alors le conseil et d'eric
drouet qui optent lara s'est montré très
soulagé et satisfait de ce verdict qui
pourrait selon lui peut-être faire
jurisprudence je vous propose de
l'écouter que c'est la fin d'un long
combat le temps a joué pour nous ce
dossier qui avait été plaidé longuement
au mois de juin dans des conditions plus
sereines
c'est justice eric drew et mais c'est
aussi justice pour tous les jeunes qui
manifestent pacifiquement
parce que c'est ça qu'on disait depuis
le départ la c2 affaire où eric gruer
avait été condamnée mis en garde à vue
pour une bougie place de la concorde et
l'autre où étaient simples manifestants
comme tous les autres sans aucun acte de
violence ait un peu de justice pour lui
mais aussi pour le mouvement des gels et
jaune donc par définition ça veut dire
qu'ils ont compris ce qu'on dit depuis
le début de façon simple et démontrer
c'est que les gels et je n'y a pas de
chef
les figures il n'y a pas de chef et que
c'est pas le le mouvement classique où
il y avait quelqu'un qui va faire un
appel que c'est plus délicat que c'est
manifestement la cour l'a entendu et
j'en suis très heureux qu'aujourd'hui
cette justice a été rendue ici à la cour
d'appel de paris
c'est une grande satisfaction
je pense que en tout cas même au niveau
du symbole c'est quand même très fort
effectivement la veille de ce genre de
cette journée de rassemblement
voilà je dirais qu'il peut y aller
tranquillement puis c'est une belle
image aussi en tout cas justice a
entendu certaines choses dit claude roy
est aussi du côté des jeunes eric drew
et ne s'est pas présenté à l'audience sa
présence n'était pas obligatoire et puis
il faut dire que ces derniers mois elle
s'est un peu mis en retrait pour se
concentrer sur son activité
professionnelle et retrouver un peu de
calme nous a dit son avocat alors la
question que tout le monde se pose
sera-t-il en revanche présents pour les
manifestations du 12 septembre
et bien selon son avocat c'est fort
possible